in this series we'll take a closer look
at specific gameplay features and dive
deeper into Middle Earth shadow of
Mordor we begin with a focus on talons
weapons and the rune upgrade system
rooms at powerful buffs Italians weapons
and are dropped as Luke when enemy
captains are vanquished exploiting the
weaknesses of an enemy will influence a
type of rooms of Trump and combining
different rooms will increase the power
of tally ins weapons in different ways
epic rooms are rare and powerful
upgrades that can make talons weapons
even more legendary crafting epic runes
to a sword or fail his bowl as card and
his dagger a card will make them known
and feared by every Beast an enemy in
Mordor finding an epic room requires
telling to dominate a captain and have
him deliver a death threat to his war
chief hearing italian is after him and
is promising a cruel death the war chief
surrounds himself with bodyguards for
protection along ship boy Oh
defeating the war chief and his gang is
no easy task but the reward is great
with the death threat fulfilled the war
chief Trump's an epic rune this
particular epic rune that's a powerful
blast of fire arrows and is only one
example a wide range of unique weapon
upgrades through a variety of
customizable rune combinations and his
weapons Italian will become a legend and
rendition Arsenal without equal